[Música]
en nuestro espacio de economía nos
acompaña nuestro colega Juan Pablo
lugumi Juan Pablo Buenos días para usted
y vamos a ponerle la lupa a lo que
estaba pasando con las siguientes
tecnologías que ha habido unos despidos
masivos en lo que va del año no Así es
María Clara desde octubre ya se hablaba
de posibles recortes pero en enero
llegaron todos ellos en las más grandes
hablamos de meta de alphabet de
Microsoft de IBM y Amazon que pues han
reducido en un porcentaje elevado pues
sus despidos a nivel Global en menos de
un mes más de 70.000 personas pues serán
despedidas o han sido despedidas esto
hablamos pues de Google aquí lo estamos
viendo meta que es la casa matriz de
Facebook con un 13% alphabet de Google
con un 6% Microsoft 5 IBM y Amazon y
esto sin contar incluso las de Twitter y
otras que también han estado por ahí
alrededor evidentemente el panorama de
inflación El Efecto rebote de la
pandemia de covid 19 y muchos otros
factores han afectado a esos factores se
le suma la sombra de una recesión que se
pronostica y la proyección de
crecimiento global que han recortado
pues considerablemente para este año
para analizar este tema le preguntamos a
Samir Estefan director ejecutivo de
texto etcétera y consultor de
transformación digital A qué se debe la
llegada de este Boom de despidos pero
cuando vemos desde octubre del año
pasado cuando empiezan compañías como
meta como Amazon a anunciar estos
despidos todas hablan de tres
condiciones básicas la primera y la más
digamos común de todas es el tema de
Cómo la inflación ha afectado la demanda
por muchos de sus servicios tanto a
nivel de consumidor final Como a nivel
corporativo por ejemplo en el caso de
compañías como Amazon como Microsoft o
como
o como Google en el que hablan de un
freno grande a lo que es el consumo de
Pauta publicitaria que para muchos de
ellos
un número importante en sus ingresos
entonces vemos la inflación es un efecto
grande el segundo es todos está incluso
aquellos a los que les ha ido bien tesla
esta semana reportó resultados positivos
sobrepasó las expectativas pero puso el
dedo en la llaga y dijo Oiga de aquí a
final de año las cosas no van a ir
también como las estamos viendo Entonces
todos han coincidido en que el segundo y
el tercer trimestre de este año no van a
ser buenos todos están esperando que
veamos por lo menos una pequeña recesión
en las principales economías
desarrolladas del mundo donde digamos
producen la mayoría de sus ingresos
bueno Juan Pablo veíamos con nuestro
analista que hay dos grandes razones
inflación y un año que no pinta tan
bueno el 2023 Pero explíqueme por qué
estas cinco grandes compañías están
despidiendo a personas todas a la vez
Pues muchas veces María Clara pasa de
que pues cuando sale solamente una de
ellas a anunciar despidos se ve como el
gran Boom pero en esta ocasión han
aprovechado todas para al mismo tiempo
Tal vez sea esa una de las razones pero
en palabras sencillas todas estaban
viendo las previsiones positivas para el
panorama mundial motivados por eso
empezaron a trazarse mayores objetivos
ambicionar en grandes ganancias y Por
ende ampliaron su plantilla laboral para
que pues esto fuera posible para
lograrlo también hacen estos despidos
previos a reportes de ganancias que
empezarán a salir en las próximas
semanas esto para que sus acciones en la
bolsa no se desplomen así lo explico o
sea Mira Estefany sí y yo creo que tal
vez ahí quien lo dijo Más claro fue Mark
Zuckerberg ya en noviembre creo que fue
cuando presentó resultados de la
compañía y decía mire nosotros nos
montamos en un bus de contratación de un
nivel esperando que la tendencia
macroeconómica de nuestros ingresos
siguiera y lo que estamos viendo cerca
de dos años después es que esa tendencia
no va a seguir estamos viendo ya primero
que se empieza a enfriar o que se
empieza a desacelerar ese crecimiento y
en algunos de los casos algunos de estas
compañías ya están viendo de
crecimientos Entonces digamos que el
impacto de sacar personal Generalmente
es un impacto de una sola vez eso qué
quiere decir que para los próximos dos
trimestres el costo de nómina va a bajar
Y eso les va a permitir que el impacto
en sus utilidades que al final es una de
las variables más importantes para
mantener el precio de la acción no sea
tan grande Juan Pablo una de las
preguntas que más nos han hecho nuestros
usuarios en las redes sociales de France
24 es porque estas compañías
tecnológicas lo primero que hacen ante
un problema es acudir a despedir
empleados en vez de por ejemplo recortar
las inversiones o recordar en otros
proyectos cuál es la respuesta María
Clara Pues esta pregunta yo también me
la hacía Y pues muchas veces es lo que
también reclaman los empleados porque
pues ante un panorama complicado lo
primero es que sufren son los
trabajadores esto ha hecho que por
ejemplo esta semana se haya dado la
primera huelga de trabajadores de Amazon
esto en Inglaterra los empleados muchas
veces dicen que las empresas ganan mucho
pagan poco y luego hacen despidos
masivos ahí nos preguntamos Por qué es
esto justo escuchemos
Sí yo creo que hay dos temas que son
importantes el primero es que
incrementar precios en un ambiente en el
cual hay un aumento a la inflación no va
a ser bueno porque digamos que todas
compiten con compañías por ejemplo
compañías chinas que pueden mantener sus
precios entonces aumentar precios es
complejo ahora no todas han anunciado
solo despido si ustedes miran Apple por
ejemplo es la única compañía del sector
de las victec que no ha anunciado
despidos esperemos que eso no cambien
las próximas dos semanas sí pero si
anunció que la compensación de Tim Cook
va a disminuir un 40% para este año
incluso Ayer
esta semana perdón el equipo de Google
también anunció que la compensación de
los de los ejecutivos top también va a
haber un un impacto en en las digamos en
los valores que se han venido pagando
hasta ahora pero pero digamos que el en
una compañía tecnología el grueso de sus
gastos es personal sí investigación
desarrollo lo hemos visto por ejemplo
compañías como Facebook como meta que
han invertido cerca de Diez mil millones
de dólares en esta apuesta del metaverso
ya le está tocando frenarlo Sí pero
muchos de ellos se juegan el hoy versus
el futuro Bueno le Quiero agradecer a
Samir y a Juan Pablo por responder esta
pregunta que tanto nos hacían y a
ustedes los invito a que sigan dejando
todas las cuestiones que tengan en
nuestras redes sociales Juan Pablo
gracias por este completo análisis y
esta respuesta aquí en la sección
económica